这放现在绝对审不过。
但是赵老师让这个戏过了。
审过。
你别管人家走不过的。
你别管人家怎么审过了，人后审过了就是英雄汉，就是牛逼。所以这部戏对我印象也是非常深。
这就是中国电视剧，我这是随便一回忆啊，肯定有遗漏啊。
嗯，跟我同龄的人肯定会有一些补充。
就我想告诉大家什么呢？就中国电视剧过去曾经非常的强，这个市场很强，不光咱们自己做的好，我们引进还引进很多。
就是。
我们曾经牛逼过中国的电视剧曾经非常牛逼，又引进国外优秀的，又往外输出，整个亚洲都看，中国的电视剧都看。
早期的时候。
这是中国电视剧的过去。
辉煌啊俩字儿。
然后中国电视剧的现在。
也用一句话总结的话，就是和国外差距越来越大。
越来越大。
这么说吧，就中国电视剧这两年退步的非常明显。
但是从国际上来说，电视剧这讲这两年蓬勃发展。
因为网络。
因为新的观看方式，新的新的收视模式带来蓬勃的发展。你去看美剧，美剧这几年真的是大发展啊。
以前美剧也没有很高啊。
以前是美剧并没有很牛逼啊，咱们是这几年觉得啊这么这那么多好看的美剧，以前并不牛逼。
这几年。
你像罪业之奔开始，然后纸排污啊，权利的游戏啊，美剧已经完全就是电影的级别，电影的规格。
非常的好看。
而且这是世界范围内的。你看韩剧，韩剧你一直就很强，但是曾经我们可以跟他并驾齐驱的。
现在他他远远的甩掉我们了。你看这几年呃，韩军的请回答系列。
前几年的什么星星的你之类的。
都是亚洲范围内。
大火的剧啊。
他们的制作水准，他们的制作理念。
已经远远把我们甩掉了。
已经远远把我们甩掉了。所以说世界范围内。
连续剧的市场。
在蓬勃的发展非常的厉害。
但是中国的电视剧这几年萎缩的很厉害。
那同学肯定就要问了，为什么萎缩了？
老师，你给说说呗。
我还在行业中啊，我又没有退休。
你让我说这个事儿。
不太好说，为什么萎缩啊？
说一下。
我认为审查。
是很重要的一个原因。
我不是说。
首先我声明一下，我不是说电视剧不用审查。
我也不是说。
审查太严，让电视剧变得质量太差。
我没有这个意思。
我想说的是什么呢？
审查现在不明确。
导致。
这才是最大的问题。就说审查不怕严。
所有的从业人员或者说很多从业人员观点都跟我一样的啊，就审查不怕严，你拿出文来。
明文规定，比如说第一条。
不许小三上位，第二条不许穿越，第三条不许呃篡改历史。第四条什么？就你如果明确出来。
那也没问题。
那也有法可依。现在其实状况是什么啊？现在其实状况是没有一直没有很明确的。
规定。
网上经常传说，广电今年1有10个禁令，或者是有什么样的。
那些其实都不是红头文件，都真的就是网传而已。
但是呢。
也绝不是无中生有，明白这个意思吗？
比如说今年不提倡，说不提倡穿越。
来，你作为一个民营的。
制作单位你穿越，你今年敢拍吗？
一拍一亿花进去，然后全部打雪漂。
所有参与的公司全部被破产。
全部都被扩产。
多少人倾家荡产？
你敢拍吗？
就这个问题。
所以说咱这儿就不多说了，好吧，因为关于审查啊，我是。
我是经历很很丰富的啊。
我经常到广电去。
什片子。
我还记得我第一次去送审的时候啊，给大家讲个小故事。
我第一次送审的时候。
当时上海我从上海到北京广电。
两个片子从上海一块过来，一个是我们。
还有另外一个片子。
然后。
拿到拿到意见之后呢。
我愁眉不展啊。
我觉得哎呀我的天哪，这哎呀，这是审查意见，我记得非常清楚，16页纸手写的正反面。
手写的正反面，当时有什么？
干部。
他手写。
十6页纸，然后跟我一块出来的呢。
一个片子，然后我就问他，我说你的。
这审查意见。
怎么这么单薄啊？他说对，就一张。
我还说我的天哪，你太幸运了。
那个我这儿你看，哎呀，我天哪，16页我怎么弄啊，正反面。
然后那个老师呢。
他就跟我说，他说小伙子，你是第一次审片吧，我说我对啊，我是第一次。
他说那你就真不懂了，他说你这个片子过了。
我说为啥呀？说说你别看你十6页纸，16页纸恰恰是写了修改意见，怎么修改？你虽然改起来很心痛，会把很多地方改的不精彩，但是至少可以改。
我这一张纸，你看看写了什么，不建议播出。
嗯。
后来他那部片子真的就没审过。
没审过那部片子叫蜗居。
叫蜗苣。
没审过没办法呀，然后拿回去改，然后那个送地方。
没有上卫星，蜗居等于是帝王台播的。
他没有拿到上星的牌照。
哎呀，所以你说。
这个审查呀。
确实是我们当时在审查意见啊呢，这十六爷子，我给你给你讲几个例子，亲嘴肯定不能亲，这就别说了啊，就写了多细啊，就没有明文规定说电视剧不许亲嘴儿。
其实一直没有这个规定，但时就给。
写出来了，说这里低俗。
对吧，然后就去讨价还价，说那我拍个后脑勺，拍后脑勺，最后商量的是必须是醇厚。
明白这个意思吗？
就说我稍微侧一点，带到一点对方的脸表达一下，这是亲嘴，不可以，只能拍醇厚。我说醇厚，你还能看出这是在亲嘴吗？完全挡住了另外一个演员了，你懂我意思吧？后来只能保留那样的镜头，还有什么？就马桶不能拍。
我有一场戏。
这个这个男女主角因为来人了，然后他们躲在马桶里，呃，不是躲在马桶里，躲在厕所里，躲在厕所里，等于是被被困在厕所了。困在厕所呢在厕所这场戏。
肯定会带到马桶嘛。
然后呢，这个修改意见里面说这场戏。
不雅。
这议删掉，然后我呢就当时我年轻啊，特别不份儿，我还跟他讨价还价，我说我没有拉屎呀。
对不对？我没有上厕所呀，我只是困在厕所里，厕所里有个马桶。
角色因为被困在厕所里时间很长，所以他会在麻桶上转一会儿，但是没有掀盖，你明白我意思吗？我也没有拉屎。而且我认为啊上厕所就电视剧中即便偶然出现上厕所。
我只要不对着拍，里面上了点什么东西。
我觉得也无上大雅。
更何况我没上啊。
然后就跟后来的不行，还是删掉了这场戏。
审查就是。
这样。
这不叫演。
因为我跟你说，你去看电视剧，有有的时候会出现马桶。
会出现甚至坐在马桶上都有。
会的。
所以说他有时候他不是盐的问题。
他是不统一。
你如果说真的是来假设有一本书这么厚都没有关系，说是中国电视剧省片规则大全，上面有写马桶不能出现。
或者是马桶出不能出现超过呃3秒钟，没问题。
你你可以。
可以呀。
但问题是没有这个规定。
那你拍了，如果这场戏就恰好很重要。
所以这里我就不多说了啊，反正我就告诉你。
有很多这个外行人觉得。
，你们就会找审查的理由，老说是审查审查。
审查真的挺。
挺头疼的。
不是嫌他严。
他没有。
明确的。
你就像穿越剧，我们又说了。
去年还是前年那个庆余年。
挺火的吧，至少当时来说挺火的。
很多人都说多牛逼。
当时那一年。
是说不提倡穿越的。
不提倡穿越。
但是穿越剧是刚需，我就这么跟你说吧，穿越剧是网剧的刚需。
什么时候拍，什么时候有人愿意看。
别人都不不不能拍。
就他上了。
这就是标准不同一。
当然可以说青云年拍的也不错，挺好的对吧？
但是。
你怎么说呢？
就像咱们一块去钓鱼，一块儿去一个地方钓鱼。
都知道那个坑鱼多鱼大好钓。
不让我们去钓啊，就他一个人在那钓，然后我们在一个很浅的水流很急的那个小河这小河里钓，那我们钓上来确实就是小泥鳅呀。
他钓上来一个这么大的鱼，然后你能说啊，人家你看人家这技术真棒。
不是这么说，我没在那个坑里掉了呀，是不是这个不多说了啊，说多矫情。我就告诉你告诉你说现在中国电视剧。
非常差。
低谷，而且。
是不正常的低谷。因为因为从世界范围内来说，电视剧正在经历。
非常上扬的一个发展期，在蓬勃的发展。
为什么蓬勃的发展？哎，你说国外的电视剧为什么这两年蓬勃的发展？
就是因为现在电视剧不是广告的弟弟了。
为什么电视剧在向电影看齐，他的制作规格越来越像电影了呢？
因为电视剧的观看方式也。
也像电影了呀。
越来越像了呀，你现在看电视剧是主动观看的呢，不是。
人家强迫你看的不是人家呃给你打麻药，让你看广告，你想看什么电视剧，你点播什么电视剧，你是自主选择了，这一点跟电影一样了吧？自主选择啊。第二。
你甚至付费了呀。
你想看那电视剧，你开始要花点钱了吧。
你付费看电视剧，看电影也是付费吗，又跟看电影又一样了。第三，你的观看设备越来越大，那个分辨率越来越高。
看的很清楚。
声音也越来越好，不是我小时候看的那个那个那个。
像微波炉一样的电视机啦。
对吧。
所以你一切的体验开始向电影看齐了。那你的制作规格、制作内容就我所以我说电视剧一直在发展变化，它在根据这个这个呃时代的不同，形态在发展变化。
就是这个原因，他他现在就是牛逼起来了，电视剧就是牛逼起来了。
所以你看以前多么高傲的那些。
所谓的骑实链说永远不碰。
电视剧的那些电影演员或者电影导演，他们没有碰电视剧，他们直接拍网剧了。
是吧。
因为时代不同了。
它就一样了。所以说电视剧一直在变化，好吧，这就是电视剧的现在的情况。
国内很低，但是国际上在迅猛的发展。
肉眼可见的牛逼啊，美剧韩剧你看这几年非常厉害。
那说完这些，我们说那第咱们中国电视剧还有未来吗？
就咱们。
还在那叭叭学电视剧的写法呢，中国电视剧还有未来。
非常有。
百分之百有。
我跟你说，电视剧的未来在哪？
就在。
未来就在技术变革。
之中，每次技术变革都是机会。
啥意思啊？
就是电视剧现在。
他理应的就是从国际上来看，他应该达到的水平在这儿。但是中国的电视剧水平现在在这儿，中间这个巨大的差距就是巨大的势能啊。
它是巨大的机会，你懂我意思吧？勤劳勇敢的中国的劳动人民。
怎么会。
做事不管呢，肯定会把这个巨大的吃能和机会给他吃掉的呀。
一定会的，但是机会出在哪呢？就出在。
技术变革的时候。
现在我们就面临着很多技术变革呀，短视频出来了吧。
5G马上来了吧。
VR也马上起来了吧，这些就是技术变革呀，技术变革就永远带来内容的变化，内容的机会。
我就是通过技术变革入行的。
我拍戏的时候啊，我刚拍戏的时候。
当时刚有视频网站。
明白这意思吗？
当时刚有优酷啊这些视频网站还没爱奇艺呢。
刚刚有视频网站。
但是。
视频网站是没有钱的。
他是不会买你的剧的，你的电视剧还你的剧还是要送到电视台。
但视频网站呢。
视频网站会干嘛呢？视频网站会。
当时那叫什么？
就盗版。
明白这意思吗？他就拿去播，他不给你钱，他拿去播。然后大部分的电视剧呃是起诉他们。
跟他们干知道吧？跟网站干，然后网站就耍赖，我还是我不管，我没钱，就网站刚出来的时候。
就就就那肯定耍赖，一个东西刚出来的时候都是耍赖的，淘宝刚出来的时候也耍赖卖假货，对吧？就就就硬卖呗，你能拿啥怎么着？然后那个呃视频网站刚出来的时候就是放盗版，就播盗版，你能拿啥怎么着，很不受待见。圈子人员人还抵制人家呢，抵制视频网站，哎呀这些。
什么呢？
我呢当时刚入行，我们的剧呢反其道而行之。为啥？因为我们在电视台不受待见，然后我们就去找那些网站说哎哎哎哎，别跑别跑回来，哎呀，不是打你，你回来啊，有库人啊，不是打我啊，你有什么事，不说你不是在放我们的剧吗？
你放我们的剧的时候，你不需要点。
宣传资料啊。
这个这个海报呀、演员的采访呀，你不需要吗？
他说啊。
可以吗？
我说怎么不可以呀，来吧，给你呀，我把演演员也不出名呀。当时我说你把演员叫来就一块上节目，一块整起来呀，是不是我说啊，是啊？我说还有你那你那放的那些片儿，那都从电视台翻录的那什么清晰度啊？我把高清的素材给你呀。
对吧然后就呃跟网站建立个紧密的合作，而且我印象非常之深。
电视台后来。
实在是可能是不好意思了啊。
可能时代也到那儿了，就是他们开始有点钱了，有点版权意识了。他说那样这样吧，我一级给你15000。
一集15000就一集电视剧给我们15000的。
版权费。
这对于一个电视剧来说就可以忽略不计，你知道吧？一级15000啊，一级15000够干嘛呢？
然后呢。
我记得非常清楚，就是一级1500。
建立了合作。
然后后来呢我们又又拍一部。
又拍下一季的时候。
然后呢，这家网站又来找我们。
说哎，你们要拍下季了，说对对对的，但是还没开始拍呢，他说没没关系。
现在就签合同。
我说那着什么急啊，他说那就没事啊，咱们老朋友了，现在签呀。
说那多多少钱一集啊？
我给大说真实数字啊，我那说。
150万亿级。
你知道当时电视台收电视剧。
是一级20万。
四个电视台就给你80万，明白这意思吗？因为是四星联播嘛。
三星或四星啊，卖有时候卖不了四星。
然后呢。
他给你150万亿级。
天价。
就惊了，你知道吗？
然后我就说我天哪，你这是发了呀，视频网站的。
潮流来了，你知道吗？但我们外界还没有感受到他们。
的时代来了，他们可能内部感受到了。
然后我就说那赶紧签呀，150万卖给他了，然后条约那合约啊也没怎么仔细看。那因为真金白银啊，有什么好聊的，人家给你钱呀，就签了。
但是我们当时还没拍。
就等于是连拍在做后期，相当于接近一年以后才能给他东西。但是他提前跟你签了合同。
150万亿。
但是你知道时代发展有多么快吗？
后来我们片子。
播的时候。
这家150万亿级买我们片子的这个平台。
不说他叫下。
他没有放我们的剧。
他450万亿级转手卖给别人。
这就是当时的时代发展就是那么快。
网站。
突然变成主力平台了。
就是网站突然变成。
有话语权的了。
然后造就了一批人。
出来了，入行了，本来挤电视台挤不进去啊，我第一次去电视台卖片。
不说哪个片子的，踩着一箱白酒卖。
电视台的台长一我一句一个干娘，一句一个干娘叫着，然后踩着一箱白酒。
但是时代就是发展那么快，技术变革出来网站谁能成想开始的时候圈子里还抵制呢？
抵制网站说这些人是盗版啊，是影视圈的吸血虫。
现在是影视圈的爸爸。
是吧。
所以说。
未来机会在哪？
技术变革呀。
以前技术变革可能20年一次，十年一次，现在技术变革是他妈两年一次、三年一次，你懂我意思吧？短视频出来之后层蹭的，我跟你说。
现在哎现在网站又变成以前的电视台了，就又开始坐那扭起来了。
放的片子越来越差，越来越像。
越来越那个店大欺客了嘛。
那你说短视频平台干不掉他们？
你有没有想过？
你以为短视频平台放不了电视剧吗？还是放不了电影吗？
他只是现在没动这个念头。
我跟你说，短视频哪怕只有3分钟一段。
他也可以放一部电影或者一整部剧。
你只需要加一个小按钮，抖音现在如果加一个小按钮，爱奇艺就慌了，加一个什么按钮连续播放。
就我拍一部剧，我放在抖音上。
虽然3分钟一段，但是可以连续播放。
两个视频之间只有0.01秒的一个蹭的一下就过去了，就很顺滑的接到下一段不行吗？
也可以吧。
那不就是又是一个新平台吗？那不就又会产生一种新模式吗？
所以那5G出来之后。
会有什么变化？
VR出来之后会有什么变化？
可以说。
这都是机会呀，你说变化太快了，我抓不住呀。你只要掌握内容就可以了呀。
你只要掌握内容不就行了吗？内容捏在你手里，内容永远是王道，永远是根本。
你把内容捏在手里。
然后跟上每次技术变革的。
的步伐。
不要嫌弃新技术。我跟你说，一个新技术出来的时候会有点丑陋。
网络刚出来的时候，淘宝刚出来的时候。
我年轻的时候。
他说21世纪初的时候啊，0几年的时候。
我跟我同学说聊天，说哎，你这双鞋哪买的？
想买它。
说这句话的时候，他会羞涩。
为啥？
言外之意就是我这双鞋是假的，网上买的，淘宝买的，一些淘宝货就代表假货，就这个意思。一个新技术出来的时候，必然会有一些不规范的行为。因为一个新大陆刚发现，首先冲过去的都是罪犯。都是野蛮人，明白了吗？
都是野蛮人呀，是吧？
所以一个新技术出来的时候，网剧刚出来的时候，那些网剧也不堪入目。
什么上尉拍的全是伪三级片，我当时管那种片子叫伪三级片，你知道吗？就起一个三级片的名字，然后吸引眼球，但是很很短暂那个时代很短暂，然后迅速的就回归回归这个内容为王。
所以我在这里说，未来是有机会的，就是大家不要看现在真的很差，就失去信心。你只要坚持做内容。
电视剧还是大有可为，因为电视剧是有它的优势的，他现在已经不是广告的弟弟了。
懂吗？
他是有它的优势的那我们具体有什么优势，具体什么写法呢？我们接着说。